Aliens where I thought it was like people who have gone on tonight show and they
had their sleeves rolled up and you know,
you ever us,
here's the crazy thing,
folks like that.
I enjoyed watching that,
but it never seemed like me.
I couldn't,
I couldn't see myself doing it.
People got to stop doing that.
They got to stop doing that.
Like,
like why are you doing a,
you're tonight show set and your Cobell is not even,
they block is so fucking disrespectful.
They block shoot these things.
Like it's,
they'll do like 10 comedians at a time and he's not even there.
And they like throw to it as if,
you know,
like he's,
it's the rudest thing I've ever heard and the fact that comedians still go on
the show and would still do it is insane of it.
Wow.
I didn't know that's it.
That's insane to me.
So how many they do in Iran?
I heard like 10 I could get the number wrong,
but he's not there.
It's not,
you know,
you're just doing like this show in front of this audience in the studio and
pretends to throw the air and your nose.
You like you're there and it's like this thing that's like,
there's nothing,
they're not,
well,
it's again man,
like,
but it's on,
it's on us as much as it's like,
you know,
of course they're going to do that.
They're going to do that to any,
you know,
any John Rowe of entertainment that would allow such a thing to happen,
they will do it to you.
Right.
You know,
they're not going to do Rihanna is doing,
uh,
these,
these things are so controlling.
Like it's the same set.
You come out in front of same curtain.
People put on the same outfit that they didn't wear yesterday and would never
wear again tomorrow.
And they come out and they pretend to be a comedian from 1993.
And so who the fuck are you?
Who the fuck are you?
What are you fucking doing for a set to get passed around to a couple of agents
that want to come see you?
That who,
yes,
I was talking to Bill Vaughn about this.
We were talking,
he knew it.
We were talking about like,
whether it's worth it being on one of those shows.
Oh No,
it's never,
it's never worth it.
It's never worth it.
Capturing yourself,
not as yourself.
It's a waste of your time.
Used to be worth something.
This is why it's confusing because there was no venues before.
So when Johnny Carson would have you on the tonight show,
yeah,
no,
and that was a listener.
It's served its purpose.
It was very important at the time.
It was an outlet where there weren't a lot of outlets and now those types of
Kafka we doing it like,
especially unless it's like,
well,
you know what that said,
you know,
Kimmel built,
he built like a,
a club like to and has like the audience travel from the studio to the club and
the comedians would do it there and it's like,
oh,
that's like an effort.
You know what I mean?
Like an effort to create this space.
So,
yeah,
it was like a space,
a separate studio that like,
you know,
I believe there's still don't,
I don't know if I've seen like a chemical set stand up set recently,
but uh,
but,
but there was like an effort,
you know,
I've always really appreciated that about like,
like come on like,
you know,
at least try like,
I dunno just tr there are too many options for comedians to go through the same
filter of capturing themselves in a way that's not authentic to them.
So you're saying that if I go on called bear,
I should do it with my shirt off.
If you want to have your shirt off as a purpose,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like you should,
you should do it.
You would deal of regular set in the belly room.
Yeah.
All right,
cool.
Well,
I mean,
because it's like,
you know,
if standup is art,
right?
If it's,
if it is an art form,
then it's supposed to be like the medium is supposed to come to the artists,
not the other way around.
You know,
because even even on those same shows,
you know,
if you see a live music performance,
like the stagings different,
it's specific to the audience,
you know,
and,
and the context of a show and a black production and you have this space,
they fill it in a way that makes sense to the artist and then it's like stand
up.
And it was just like,
you could just go through a slide show of just the exact same think,
you know?
Well,
I guess when a musical artists gets on Cole Bear,
one of those shows,
they're already kind of famous,
right?
They already have an album out and when a standup gets on those shows,
they're trying to get seen.
Like maybe you don't have a special yet.
Maybe you're just,
you showcased and they picked a few people.
You've done any of it yet.
I don't do any of those specific reason.
Yeah,
I liked it.
I remember one time like,
uh,
I,
I was going to do Letterman while Letterman was on Letterman and I remember
sending a,
uh,
set in or whatever and uh,
they respond.
I was like,
okay,
you know,
we could do it,
but could he do his jokes in the more traditional setup punchline format?
And I remember just like emailing back,
well,
I'll just do it when I'm famous.
Okay,
well I'm just not going to listen to this bullshit.
No.
People,
they change.
That's the other thing they change again.
Compare yourself to a musician.
Imagine you're a musician going on and they're like,
we like the song,
but could the bridge come first and then you do the,
you will be like,
go fuck yourself.
Right?
Comedians allow,
like,
you can't say pop tart if you say pop.
Exactly.
Comedians allow a lot of shit.
The pastry.
Can you say a pastry like,
but that doesn't make any sense.
We just tried to hit the road.
Derive toaster strudel is a spot that's trying to hit the roads,
right?
No Man.
Do you,
man,
why?
I wouldn't do it.
Even back in the day,
it didn't make any sense to me.
There would go,
you should put together a five minute set for the tonight show and I'd be like,
I don't want to do it.
And they're like,
you should do it.
Like it's,
it's good exposure is like the fucking nineties right.
When it actually probably meant something and I was like,
I don't,
I don't see it happening.
I'm not doing,
hey,
it's not stand up.
You're,
you're,
you're taking a little piece of it.
Stand up.
Like a short set is 15 minutes and if 15 minutes I might cover two concepts,
you know,
because I need time.
I go over things like I get thorough of,
I'm,
if I'm talking about a subject,
I get involved in that subject.
I want to,
I want to bring people on a journey and I also want to be able to set them up.
I want to be able to explain how I think about things so that by the time I get
to something controversial,
they already have a sense of how I approach things.
You can't do that.
And five minutes in five minutes.
You just got to just get into it and it's a very condensed,
homogenized version of who you really are.
Man.
It just do it.
Just do a late night spot with a five minute set up.
Then leave
justice set up.
Yeah.
Just to set up is shake.
I remember I saw Louis Do one,
Louis C K did one,
one of those Letterman or tonight show or something like that and I was like
God,
like he shouldn't even do this.
Cause it's,
it's not,
it's such a,
not a good representation of what he's capable.
Well some people are like Jerry Seinfeld should do.
Yeah.
That he should absolutely do that.
He could do it.
When he does.
He does.
I love Jerry's a tonight show sets.
Yeah.
And his like his makes sense.
It makes sense.
It's like perfect for and it's like,
it translates very,
very well.
But when I watch those shows
today,
I'm like,
why are they still a thing when I see a late night show?
And no disrespect to anybody who hosts a late night show.
But to me it's like,
it's like they took a boat and try to turn it into a plane.
Oh,
they're like,
hey man,
it's 2018 but let's pretend it's not.
But I,
we'll be right back with the commercial.
Hey,
we're going to have commercials.
You're going to do commercials in the thing.
But today everybody watches HBO and Netflix.
Like,
what am I doing here?
Sitting through a fucking commercial?
I get,
it may be weird like,
cause I actually,
I enjoy advertising to do.
Yeah.
I like a lot,
I'll stare at like billboards or watch commercials of Watch,
like,
oh,
because I do think it,
it speaks to what,
uh,
like America thinks we are as a culture.
Right?
And you know what I mean?
It speaks to what they think is appealing and what they think is going to work.
And so in a sense,
it's like in a way,
in the same sense,
like you can gauge a lot from a person by the types of questions they ask you.
You know,
you can gauge a lot from like even a climate by the type of commercials,
what they feel is because they're trying to appeal to everybody.
So this is what they're saying.
This is what we think everybody is thinking right now.
You know,
know or how everyone feels or what they want.
And,
uh,
but I,
I love,
uh,
like I'll watch it and even like the tonight show and those,
um,
these things,
I mean,
look,
you know,
anything in function at its best is fun.
It's just,
you know,
the,
where it hits a wall and just what we're saying about comedy and what we're
saying about a lot of things.
It's like when a thing tries to be something that it's not right.
You know,
when it feels like they're just these late night shows when they're just doing
fun things that they think are fun and interesting.
I love,
Ya know,
Kimmel always every year.
It does like the parents to tell the kids that know Halloween that they ate all
the Halloween candy and the kids' reactions and stuff like that.
I eat that stuff up.
I love that you want to be like,
it's so sketchy,
but fun.
But,
but like when it,
you know,
when shows pretend to be,
1989 it's just like when comedians pretending to be of a different era,
pretend to it,
it just feels false.
And I think that's where you check out.
Yeah.
It's just unnecessary at this point,
you know,
because of the Internet,
you just have too many other venues.
Yeah.
Well it's a lot of options.
A lot of options.
Yeah.
And the vent,
like watching things on the Internet,
it's so much more satisfying.
It's like watching a comic on a podcast.
You're going to get his chance,
chance to see who the fuck they really are instead of some weird set in front of
some audiences that got shipped in from Burbank and they got applause signs and
everything.
It's very surreal when you go to a live taping and you watch that.
It's really surreal.
Oh,
it's very like,
and I'll sit it,
I have like,
you know,
it's always what I have weird uh,
late night cause I like I'm bad at being like the,
you know,
celebrity type of thing.
Like I'm just in it and just like looking at it and when the crowd is giving an
unnatural reaction to things is just like,
what do you,
right.
You too introspective.
You're not going to just dive in fake.
I'm like,
hey,
hey bro,
what are we doing?
What is this like?
What are you,
is this rewarding for you?
Applaud side everybody.
What are we doing?
The uncomfortable moment?
This is where we'll be right back.
Thank you.
We'll be right back.
That we'll be right back.
Shit.
It's like,
where are you going?
You promised they put shut those commercials in later.
Just keep rolling.
Fuck.
Are we doing for you right back.